going to the media now there there have
been uh there's been a whole slate of
layoffs at Major media companies in
recent weeks and rather than tell you
about it or read something about it I
will let Taylor Loren who's the
Washington Post propagandist one of one
of their several one of their many
propagandas they have on the payroll uh
she recorded a video very very
distraught and upset about the state of
the media now and how they're all losing
their jobs and let's listen to
her journalism industry is basically in
a free fall today the Los Angeles Times
laid off 115 employees they wiped out
their entire DC Bureau in an election
year they laid off pretty much all of
their sports teams they killed their
entire Tech and business section they
laid off breaking news writers social
media editors the list goes on but
what's really dark is this is just the
latest in months and months and months
of layoffs in the media industry in fact
tens of thousands of journalists have
been laid off in the past year major
media companies like BuzzFeed news have
completely shut shuttered their news
operations Time Magazine also just laid
off a ton of people and oh Sports
Illustrated basically shut down last
week pretty much the entire digital
media ecosystem that myself and a lot of
other Millennial journalists came up in
has been completely hollowed out and
it's not just digital media sites local
news has been obliterated the newspaper
industry is cratering Radio is
essentially dead aside from NPR which
has been gutted meanwhile hundreds of
workers at K Nas the parent company of
pretty much every major magazine from GQ
to Vogue to the New Yorker to Vanity
Fair are on strike because they're also
facing impending layoffs even mainstream
National media Outlets owned by
billionaires like the Washington Post
where I work and the Atlantic where I
used to work have done layoffs if you're
a young journalist today there's almost
no onramp to traditional journalism even
if you do get a job journalists salaries
have been stagnant and even declined and
by the way we don't make that much to
begin with I don't think people
understand how bad the world would be
without
journalists uh the thing about this is
that she she's saying all this like it's
a bad thing and she wants us to be upset
but everyone is receiving it as uh as
glorious news so this is like she's
basically she's basically telling us
that it's Christmas morning but she
wants us to be sad about it and uh so
there's something's being lost in in
Translation there because unfortunately
uh like pretty much everybody else I
can't weep for the poor journalists uh I
can't feel sorry for them feeling sorry
for a journalist it it's like feeling
sorry for a tick that you just pulled
off of your dog's ear like it's not I I
couldn't even experience that emotion if
I wanted to I just have no sympathy to
give here uh so why is Corporate media
falling apart well there are two reasons
it's not just the reason that
conservatives will immediately point to
although there is that too that I mean
that is the first reason that the the
fact that the journalism profession has
completely discredited itself it has
unabashedly become a form of left-wing
advocacy
and on the right we've been saying this
forever to the point that it just
becomes background noise but this is
this is what we were talking about this
is the uh you know there are many
consequences of that and the culture has
experienced the consequences of the
journalism profession becoming nothing
but pretty much left-wing uh activism a
lot of
consequences and and and but
Downstream far less severe Downstream of
all that is like eventually those
eventually the journalism profession
itself starts to reap those consequences
and so for years and years and years
when those of us on the right were
saying the media is hop like to call it
biased is is is doesn't capture the
problem at this point so far beyond bias
this is just straight up leftwing
advocacy making no with no pretention of
being anything
else and we've been saying that we've
been saying that and the people in the
media like terl Loren have been ignoring
us and laughing at us and all that they
don't well here you go this is what
happens now you're all losing your
jobs uh now you're all broke and you're
losing your jobs and these entire once
prestigious
storied uh companies and outlets and
Publications are are going
under um and this is a big reason why
why and also one of the reasons why
why we feel so okay with gloating about
it because usually people lose their
jobs you know generally speaking people
lose their jobs I'm not going to gloat
about it I don't I'm not happy about it
I don't like people lose their jobs but
there are some exceptions okay like if I
hear that an abortion clinic shut shut
down and everybody lost their job I'm
very happy and if you worked at abortion
and you lost your job and now you are
personally bankrupt I'm happy about that
you deserve it that's Justice I'm very
very happy about it you worked at
abortion clinic you lost your job and
now you're out on the street homeless I
am happy you deserve that that's Justice
that you know the suffering you are
feeling you deserve it is Justice
keeping your windshields clean is always
a pain especially in the winter dirt and
salt pile up and washer fluid just can't
get the job done that's where my friends
at windshield wow come in to save the
day windshield wow is an Innovative
windshield cleaning device that uses two
magnetic cleaning paddles one on one
side and one on the other on the inside
of your car uh tolean clean both sides
of your windshield all from the outside
all you do is push around the outside
paddle and the inside follows
automatically leaving your windshield
squeaky clean I personally own a
windshield wow this is one of the best
products for my car windshield being
able to clean both the front and the
inside window at the same time as an
absolute Game Changer wish I had one of
these years ago the windshield well
applies firm cleaning pressure and is
super thin to get into those tight
dashboard areas so what are you waiting
for go to windshield wild.com use code
Walsh at checkout for a special discount
that's windshield wow.com and use code
Walsh now the journalism industry is not
quite as bad as that but um it is still
some many of these people are just they
have no Integrity they're very bad
people and on top of
that you know they have in the
media uh destroyed the lives of anyone
they deem an enemy even just normal
people like civilians who for whatever
reason find themselves in the left's
crosshairs and they get destroyed that's
a lot when we talk about cancel culture
that's a lot of what we're talking
about um usually the more high-profile
sort of victims of cancel culture are
the ones who get the
attention there's a lot of other people
we talk about cancel culture we're
talking about a lot of times just normal
people who for whatever reason end up
trending on social media or whatever it
is the media jumps in and and tries to
ruin win
them
um and then the very people who do that
they lose their jobs and what we're
supposed we're supposed to not gloat
about it it's like you deserve to lose
your
job you you're a very bad person you
have no Integrity you have delighted in
in in your cruelty towards other people
and now you lost your
job um so why are these companies dying
nobody trusts them nobody likes them
nobody wants to hear from them and you
are a business that runs on trust trust
is your product really it's what you're
selling and if you don't have it if
nobody trusts you then it's over and you
know I guess you could say that that's
basically true of every industry every
industry fundamentally is really selling
trust you have to trust whatever it is
they're sell whatever is they're
actually selling it's like that all
based in trust people have to trust if
you're if you're an architect who makes
Bridges and next thing you know bridges
are falling apart part all over the
country uh nobody trusts the bridg
makers anymore and then your business is
going to die the only difference is that
we need Bridges whereas we do not need
what Taylor Loren provides and that kind
of goes to the other big problem for the
media which is
oversaturation Extreme oversaturation
this is a problem we all deal with you
know everybody in media deals with it um
with and you know I'm in media too I
always I do think it's funny when people
in conservative media talk about media
likely aren't in the media themselves I
mean there I there is a distinction
where you know here like there's the
leftwing corporate press which we are
not but yeah we we are in uh we are in
the media business and
um and
so while we are not left-wing
propagandists who Delight in the in
destroying and and you know normal
people who did nothing wrong uh we're
still in the media so we do we do deal
with the second problem which is the
which is the oversaturation problem
there's so much media all of our lives
are dominated by media all the time
people are ingesting media basically
every waking second of the day which
means that the media business has never
been wider right but it's also never
been more shallow and what I mean by
that is that there's never been more
people in the media business there have
never probably never been never more
there never been more companies you know
media companies and people but the but
at the same time the value of the
content has also never been more
diminished so that even if you don't
have the massive trust issue that the
leftwing Press has the other problem is
that
um for so many people in media whatever
you're doing can be found a million
other
places like people blame Sports
illustrated's collapse on uh on its
wokeness and that's fair like that
definitely had a lot to do with it but
also who needs Sports Illustrated anyway
like what what what do they do that
isn't being
done just as well in so many other
places 10 years ago or so I was a pretty
uh Avid Reader of the Sports Illustrated
website I would go there all the time
but I bailed out long before they
started putting trans and morbidly obese
people in their swimsuit edition or
whatever I stopped reading it long
before that because you know if I want
to get people Sports takes I can go to
Twitter or I can go to YouTube or any of
a hundred Sports blogs everything gets
drowned everything is being drowned by
everything
else what's the solution well I I I
think I hope the solution is to create
meaningful high quality content and um
and offer unique interesting analysis
and perspective that you can't get a
million other
places uh the fact is that 95% of media
content is interchangeable and
indistinguishable most of it can be
replaced by Ai and that's already
happening a lot of it already has been
we just don't you just don't know it
when you read the
articles um even most of the
commentary that you hear from from
corporate media Outlets or whatever most
of the commentary could be replicated by
a mildly Advanced
chatbot which means that if you're in
the business if you're in my business
you need to be in that
5% uh to have any job security at all I
like to think we're into 5% that's my
goal anyway hey YouTube thanks for
listening to the show if you'd like
access to my full show with no ads you
should go to dailywire.com and use promo
code Walsh to get two months free on all
annual plans see you there